Ласкаво просимо назад до курсу з розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень. Мене звуть Джон Уотрес, я технічний директор з освіти в IBM
Quantum. Це 16-й і останній урок серії, а тема уроку — відмовостійкі квантові
обчислення. Протягом трьох попередніх уроків ми розглянули кілька прикладів квантових кодів виправлення помилок, які можуть виявляти та дозволяти нам
виправляти квантові помилки, поки їх не надто багато. Якщо ми хочемо використовувати виправлення помилок для квантових обчислень, однак, є ще багато
питань, з якими треба розібратися, включно з реальністю того, що наші квантові gate, вимірювання та підготовка
станів самі по собі, ймовірно, будуть недосконалими. Так, наприклад, якщо ми збираємося виконувати виправлення помилок для одного
або більше qubit, закодованих за допомогою квантового коду виправлення помилок, то нам доведеться робити це за допомогою gate і вимірювань, які самі по собі
мають шанс не спрацювати правильно. А це означає не лише невдачу у виявленні або виправленні помилок, але й можливе
внесення нових помилок. Крім того, нам також потрібно виконувати самі обчислення, які нас цікавлять, знову ж таки за допомогою gate, які не є
досконалими. І ми, звичайно, не можемо ризикувати декодуванням квантової інформації заради виконання обчислень, а потім
повторним кодуванням після завершення, бо помилки можуть виникнути, коли захист квантового коду виправлення помилок відсутній.
Це означає, що нам треба з'ясувати, як виконувати квантові gate безпосередньо на логічних qubit, які ніколи не залишаються без
захисту квантового коду виправлення помилок. Це непросте завдання, але відомо, що поки рівень шуму
падає нижче певного порогового значення, насправді можливо виконувати довільно великі квантові обчислення надійно за допомогою зашумленого обладнання, принаймні
в теорії. І ми обговоримо цей критично важливий факт пізніше в уроці. Ось короткий огляд
уроку. Ми почнемо з базової моделі для відмовостійких квантових обчислень, включно з коротким обговоренням
моделей шуму разом із загальною методологією реалізації квантового circuit відмово
стійко. Потім ми перейдемо до питання поширення помилок у відмовостійких квантових circuit і до того, як
це контролювати. Зокрема, я розгляну трансверсальні реалізації gate, які пропонують дуже простий спосіб контролювати поширення помилок.
Хоча є фундаментальне обмеження, яке не дає нам використовувати цей метод
виключно. Я також розповім про іншу методологію, пов'язану з так званими магічними станами, яка пропонує інший шлях до контролю поширення помилок
у відмовостійких квантових circuit. Хоча це не єдиний відомий метод, і нарешті урок
завершується досить детальним обговоренням теореми про поріг, на яку я щойно натякнув.
Ця теорема стверджує, що довільно великі квантові circuit можуть бути реалізовані надійно, поки рівень помилок усіх компонентів,
що беруть участь, падає нижче певного кінцевого порогового значення. Загалом це порогове значення
залежить від коду виправлення помилок, який ми використовуємо, а також від конкретних рішень, які ми ухвалюємо щодо відмовостійких реалізацій
квантових gate і вимірювань, але не від розміру circuit, що реалізується. І це дає нам вагомі підстави вважати, що масштабні
квантові обчислення колись стануть реальністю. Ми почнемо з обговорення базової моделі для відмовостійких квантових
обчислень, яка природно базується на квантових circuit і квантових кодах виправлення помилок. Для цього обговорення
уявімо, що у нас є квантовий circuit, який ми сподіваємося реалізувати, наприклад той, що показаний тут. Так вийшло, що це
circuit телепортації, включно з підготовкою EBIT. Але деталі не дуже важливі для цього обговорення. І ти можеш уявити, що
це будь-який інший квантовий circuit, можливо набагато більший circuit, який включає підготовку станів, унітарні
операції та вимірювання. Цей circuit, звичайно, являє собою ідеал, а фактична
його реалізація не буде досконалою. Закономірне питання: що могло б піти
не так? Ну, є дуже багато чого, що могло б піти не так. Наприклад, ініціалізації стану, як правило, не будуть
досконалими. Звісно, унітарні gate не будуть досконалими, як і
вимірювання. Більш того, самі qubit будуть сприйнятливі до шуму, включно з декогеренцією, у кожний момент
обчислення, навіть коли нічого не відбувається з цими qubit і вони просто зберігають квантову інформацію. Іншими словами, практично
все може піти не так. Є один виняток, хоча це принаймні типове припущення,
а саме те, що будь-які класичні обчислення, що беруть участь, мабуть, не будуть хибними, тому що з усіх практичних міркувань
класичні обчислення в основному є досконалими. Так, наприклад, якщо ми запускаємо класичний алгоритм зіставлення для
обчислення виправлень для помилок поверхневого коду, нам справді не потрібно турбуватися про те, що це класичне обчислення може бути хибним. Але все, що безпосередньо
стосується квантової інформації, може бути. Звичайно, нам потрібна точна модель, за допомогою якої ми можемо пов'язати
ймовірності різних речей, що можуть піти не так. І якщо ми захочемо, ми можемо придумати настільки складну модель, яка нам подобається, щоб сподіватися відобразити те, що
насправді відбувається в реальності. Якщо модель надто складна, однак, вона може виявитися важкою або неможливою для роботи або для того, щоб сказати
щось цікаве. Один дуже простий приклад моделі шуму, яку люди часто розглядають,
— це модель незалежного стохастичного шуму, де помилки або збої, що впливають на різні компоненти в різні
моменти, або іншими словами, різні розташування в circuit, є незалежними.
Наприклад, ми могли б сказати, що кожен gate виходить з ладу з певною ймовірністю, що бітові перекидання та фазові перекидання трапляються зі збереженими qubit з різною
ймовірністю за одиницю часу тощо. Але припущення полягає в тому, що між різними
помилками немає кореляції. Ти можеш заперечити проти цієї моделі, оскільки, мабуть, між
помилками будуть певні кореляції. Наприклад, є, мабуть, невелика ймовірність катастрофічної помилки, яка одразу знищить усі qubit.
Або, що більш ймовірно, можуть бути помилки, що локалізовані, але тим не менш впливають на кілька компонентів.
І ніхто не стверджує іншого. Але тим не менш, ця модель являє собою просту базову лінію, яка по
суті відображає ідею, що природа непередбачувана, але вона не є злоякісною і не намагається навмисно
зруйнувати квантові обчислення. Існують інші, можна сказати, більш реалістичні моделі шуму, які часто розглядаються. І незалежно від
моделі, яку ми вибираємо, якщо виявиться, що наша модель заводить нас в оману і ми дізнаємося щось нове про помилки в
будь-якій системі, з якою ми працюємо, ми можемо природно формулювати та розглядати різні моделі помилок. Далі ми
розглянемо базову стратегію реалізації квантових circuit відмовостійко. Тож розглянемо даний
логічний квантовий circuit, тобто ідеальний квантовий circuit, який нас цікавить для запуску. Наприклад, ми могли б розглянути той самий circuit, що й
раніше, який тепер дещо розтягнутий, тому що нам знадобиться трохи більше місця для відмовостійкої реалізації. По-перше,
WEBVTT
підготовка станів, унітарні gate і вимірювання не виконуватимуться безпосередньо як одиночні gate або як
одиночні вимірювання qubit або підготовки стану, а натомість вони виконуватимуться так званими гаджетами, які
можуть кожен включати кілька qubit і кілька операцій. Тут на цій діаграмі я
проілюстрував це, намалювавши фіолетові рамки навколо цих речей. І ти можеш думати про ці фіолетові рамки як про маленькі circuit або операції, які
лише позначені тим, яку підготовку стану або gate ми маємо намір реалізувати. По-друге, нам потрібно захистити
qubit за допомогою коду виправлення помилок. Тому це не самі логічні qubit, які з'єднують ці різні гаджети, а гаджети діють на
фізичні qubit, які кодують ці логічні qubit. І варто підкреслити тут, що логічні qubit, про які нам важливо
знати, ніколи не відкриті, тобто ці логічні qubit проводитимуть усе своє існування під захистом того,
який квантовий код виправлення помилок ми використовуємо. І нарешті, ми виконуємо виправлення помилок на наших закодованих qubit
неодноразово протягом усього обчислення, в основному щоразу, коли у нас є можливість. І критично важливо, щоб ми це
робили. Образно кажучи, оскільки виникають помилки, випадковість або невизначеність починає накопичуватися у стані наших
qubit, і нам потрібно постійно працювати, щоб усувати цю випадковість або ентропію. І це відбувається через виправлення помилок.
Тож ти можеш думати про ці кроки виправлення помилок як про маленькі логічні холодильники або теплові насоси, які
дозволяють логічним qubit залишатися «холодними», щоб обчислення могли працювати правильно.
Коли всі ці вибори зроблені, тобто вибір усіх гаджетів, а також коду, і припускаючи конкретну модель шуму, є
фундаментальне питання, яке ми можемо собі поставити, а саме: чи це насправді допомагає. Ми покращуємо ситуацію чи
погіршуємо? Якщо шуму надто багато, ми цілком могли б погіршити ситуацію,
так само як 9-qubit код Шора погіршує ситуацію, якщо шанс помилки надто великий.
Але якщо шум нижче певного порогу, то вся ця додаткова робота дасть результат. І як ми обговоримо ближче до кінця уроку,
відкриваються шляхи для подальшого зниження помилки. У цій частині уроку ми обговоримо поширення помилок у відмово
стійких квантових circuit, що мають базову структуру, яку я щойно описав. Виявляється, це
є першочерговою проблемою, тому що якщо нам не вдасться контролювати поширення помилок, помилки швидко переважать наші зусилля з
виправлення помилок. Але якщо ми здатні контролювати поширення помилок, то наш код матиме набагато кращі шанси
встигати, щоб помилки могли виправлятися з достатньо високою швидкістю, щоб дозволити нашим обчисленням
працювати. Відправною точкою для цього обговорення є усвідомлення того, що двокубітні gate або багатокубітні gate загалом
можуть поширювати помилки навіть тоді, коли вони функціонують правильно.
Наприклад, розглянемо gate C not. І припустимо, що помилка X виникає на контрольному qubit перед виконанням gate C not.
Ну, помилка X функціонує так само, як gate X. І ми знаходимо, що
circuit ліворуч еквівалентний тому, що праворуч, де помилки X виникають на обох qubit після C
not. Це поширення помилок, тому що нещасливе розташування помилки X ліворуч фактично перетворює її
на дві помилки X праворуч. І ми ніколи не оминемо цього. Поки ми використовуємо gate C not, завжди є
шанс, що помилка X виникне на контрольному qubit безпосередньо перед ним, яка потім поширюється до двох помилок X
після. Але, як ми побачимо, поки ми вживаємо заходів для обмеження шкоди, яку це спричиняє, все буде добре. До речі,
те саме явище виникає, коли у нас є помилка Z на цільовому qubit безпосередньо перед C not. І ми обговорювали це
раніше, і ти можеш перевірити ці рівності, просто виконавши множення, або можеш перевірити їх за допомогою
Qiskit. Суть полягає в тому, що це в обох випадках спричинить корельовані помилки на кількох qubit. І, звичайно, ми
не повинні забувати, що самі gate C not також можуть бути несправними, що також може спричинити корельовані
помилки. Додаючи до нашого занепокоєння, наступні двокубітні gate можуть поширювати ці помилки ще далі.
Наприклад, якщо у нас є три gate C not, як тут, як ми знаходимо при вимірюванні X-генераторів стабілізатора, наприклад, то одна помилка може
швидко поширитися на кілька qubit. І якщо це трапляється всередині одного блоку коду, наприклад, тобто купки
qubit, які разом кодують логічний qubit, який би код виправлення помилок ми не вибрали, не матиме
шансів, тому що коди розроблені для виправлення помилок малої ваги, а не помилок великої ваги.
І тому це те, що ми маємо тримати в першу чергу на увазі, коли думаємо про гаджети та
кроки виправлення помилок у відмовостійких квантових circuit. Найпростіший відомий спосіб пом'якшити поширення помилок у відмово
стійких квантових circuit — реалізовувати gate трансверсально, і я поясню, що це означає,
за мить. Тож залишимо на екрані рисунок нашої відмовостійкої реалізації circuit просто як візуальну підказку.
Ідея тут полягає в тому, що для деяких квантових кодів виправлення помилок певні gate можуть бути реалізовані трансверсально, що
означає реалізацію їх за допомогою гаджетів, які є тензорними добутками операцій, де кожна операція діє лише на
одну позицію qubit всередині кожного блоку коду. Це найлегше пояснити на прикладах. Перший і,
мабуть, найпростіший приклад — трансверсальні реалізації gate Паулі.
Ідея полягає в тому, що ми хочемо побудувати гаджети для кожного з gate у нашому circuit. І в усіх випадках ці гаджети
оперують блоками коду, як ми бачимо для gate X і Z в кінці нашого circuit телепортації. Звичайно, ми
не можемо декодувати, застосовувати gate Паулі, а потім повторно кодувати, тому що це залишить логічний qubit незахищеним, і помилки
можуть поширюватися всередині блоку коду в результаті повторного кодування.
На щастя, нам не потрібно цього робити, поки ми використовуємо стабілізаторний код, тому що кожен стабілізаторний код дозволяє застосовувати операції Паулі
безпосередньо до наших логічних qubit. І насправді ми можемо робити це за допомогою тензорного добутку gate Паулі
на фізичних qubit, що використовуються для кодування.
Наприклад, якщо ми розглянемо поверхневий код 3x3, який з'явився в кінці попереднього уроку, то ми можемо реалізувати gate X і Z на логічному
qubit, закодованому цим кодом, об'єднуючи разом gate X і Z разом з тотожними gate у візерунках,
запропонованих тут. Це трансверсальна реалізація цих gate, тому що кожна з цих окремих операцій gate
діє лише на одну позицію qubit всередині кожного блоку коду.
WEBVTT
Тут ми використовуємо лише одно-кубітні gate, тому це якоюсь мірою тривіально, але в будь-якому разі такі гаджети не спричинять поширення помилок.
Тепер, будь-який з окремих gate у такому гаджеті може відмовити, і це введе
помилки, але ми завжди виконуватимемо виправлення помилок одразу після кожного гаджета. І поки рівень помилок достатньо
низький, код виправлення помилок виправить ці помилки.
І як я вже сказав, це завжди можливо для gate Паулі для кожного стабілізаторного коду.
Хоча тобі треба визначити правильний візерунок gate Паулі в гаджетах, щоб правильно реалізувати ту логічну операцію Паулі, яку ти
хочеш. Для іншого прикладу, який включає двокубітні gate. Цього разу ми можемо розглянути трансверсальні реалізації
gate C not. Зокрема, для кожного CSS-коду ми завжди можемо реалізувати gate C not
між двома логічними qubit, просто виконуючи gate C not на відповідних парах фізичних
qubit. І це задовольняє умову трансверсальності, тому що кожен з цих окремих gate C not діє лише
на одну позицію qubit всередині кожного блоку коду. Наприклад, перший gate C not діє лише на найверхній qubit
всередині кожного блоку коду. Другий gate C not діє лише на другий зверху qubit і так
далі. У цьому випадку може відбуватися поширення помилок, тому що gate C not поширюють помилки, і немає
способу запобігти цьому. Але ключ у тому, що поширення помилок ніколи не відбувається всередині одного блоку коду. Наприклад,
помилка X може виникнути на верхньому qubit верхнього блоку коду безпосередньо перед виконанням гаджета, і перший C not
всередині гаджета поширить цю помилку на верхній qubit у нижньому блоці. Але дві помилки, що виникли,
тепер знаходяться в окремих блоках коду. Тому кроки виправлення помилок, що відбуваються після гаджета, зможуть виправити ці помилки окремо, тому що ці
помилки впливають лише на один qubit всередині кожного блоку коду.
Натомість якби поширення помилок відбувалося всередині того самого блоку коду, ми могли б мати проблему, тому що
тоді поширення помилок перетворює помилку малої ваги на помилку більшої ваги, яку наш код може не вміти обробляти.
Ця реалізація не працює для не-CSS-кодів, але поки ми використовуємо CSS-код, ми завжди можемо реалізовувати gate C not
трансверсально в такий спосіб. І ще для одного прикладу, кожен
gate Кліффорда може бути реалізований трансверсально для коду Стіна. І насправді для будь-якого кольорового коду, що є однією з дійсно приємних речей в кольорових
кодах — зокрема gate Hadamard на логічному qubit може бути реалізований виконанням gate Hadamard окремо на
кожному з фізичних qubit, а логічний gate S може бути реалізований не gate S на кожному qubit, а скоріше
gate S† на кожному фізичному qubit. Тож суть у тому, що трансверсальні реалізації gate є по суті
відмовостійкими, тому що вони ніколи не поширюють помилки всередині одного блоку коду, що дає крокам виправлення помилок шанс виправити
будь-які помилки, введені або поширені gate, що використовуються для цих гаджетів. Це чудово, і це
дійсно простий спосіб будувати відмовостійкі гаджети, і є різні коди, що дозволяють трансверсальні реалізації різних gate, як-от
T gate, але на жаль неможливо для будь-якого нетривіального коду реалізовувати
універсальний набір gate трансверсально, що є фактом, відомим як теорема Істіна-Кнілла, а більш технічно це
означає, що поки наш код має відстань принаймні дві, набір gate, що може бути реалізований трансверсально, буде обов'язково породжувати
дискретний набір операцій з точністю до глобальної фази, і тому цей набір не є універсальним, тому що універсальні набори gate
обов'язково породжують нескінченно багато операцій. Я не буду пояснювати доведення цієї теореми, що використовує деякі
базові факти про групи Лі та алгебри Лі, які не є необхідними умовами для цієї серії. Але базова ідея полягає в тому,
що нескінченні сімейства трансверсальних операцій не можуть тримати нас усередині кодового простору, тому що мізерні
відмінності в трансверсальних операціях добре апроксимуються операціями Паулі малої ваги, які код виявляє як
помилки. Тому ми дуже раді, коли можемо реалізовувати gate трансверсально. Але для будь-якого коду, який ми вибираємо, ми знаємо, що
завжди матимемо певні gate, які не можемо реалізовувати в цей спосіб. Тому нам потрібно шукати альтернативні гаджети. За
теоремою Істіна-Кнілла, ми знаємо, що неможливо реалізовувати універсальний набір квантових gate трансверсально навіть
для мізерного квантового коду виправлення помилок відстані 2. Тому нам потрібно знайти інші способи реалізувати gate відмово
стійко принаймні для деяких gate. Один відомий спосіб це зробити — через використання так званих магічних
станів. Для цілей цього обговорення, пригадаймо gate S і T, які є
одно-кубітними gate, визначеними так, як показано тут на екрані. Зазначимо також, що по-перше, S є операцією Кліффорда,
що випливає з нашого визначення операцій Кліффорда. Але ти також можеш перевірити, що кон'югування матриці Паулі за допомогою S завжди дає нам плюс або мінус іншої
матриці Паулі. І по-друге, T не є операцією Кліффорда. Насправді, якщо ми поєднаємо T з Hadamard і C not, обидва з яких є
операціями Кліффорда, ми отримуємо універсальний набір квантових gate. Тому ми не можемо реалізувати gate T
використовуючи лише операції Кліффорда та вимірювання у стандартному базисі. Але ми насправді можемо реалізувати gate T за допомогою
операцій Кліффорда та вимірювань у стандартному базисі, якщо додатково маємо копію стану, показаного тут на
екрані, який є gate T, застосованим до стану плюс.
Цей стан називається магічним станом, хоча він не є унікальним у цьому відношенні.
Термін «магічний стан» також використовується для позначення різних станів, що відіграють подібну роль до цього в варіаціях усієї цієї
схеми. Наприклад, цей circuit, показаний тут, виконує роботу. І перевірити це не надто складно.
Ось початковий стан з верхньою системою праворуч. І якщо ми застосовуємо gate C not і спрощуємо, ми отримуємо
стан, показаний тут.
Тож якщо ми вимірюємо нижній qubit і отримуємо нуль, що трапляється з ймовірністю 1/2, ми не виконуємо
gate S, і вихід — T, застосований до s.
І якщо ми вимірюємо одиницю, що також трапляється з ймовірністю 1/2, ми звичайно застосовуємо gate S і кінцевий результат —
вихід знову T, застосований до s. Це, до речі, не єдиний спосіб це зробити. Є інші схожі circuit,
що досягають того самого результату, але це один із способів.
Це дещо спрощений приклад чогось відомого як квантова телепортація gate, на що я натякнув ще в уроці 4, де телепортація використовується
WEBVTT
не для надсилання qubit, а для застосування gate. Зв'язок з телепортацією може бути не зовсім очевидний тут, тому що, як я
вже сказав, це спрощена версія, яку ми можемо використати, оскільки T є діагональним. Але якщо тебе цікавить
більше дізнатися, ключові слова — квантова телепортація gate.
І ми могли б зробити щось подібне для реалізації gate S, де цього разу єдині gate, які нам потрібні — це gate C not і gate Z разом із вимірюванням,
що корисно, якщо у нас немає трансверсальної реалізації gate S. Це цікаво, але не зовсім
зрозуміло, що це насправді допомагає. У випадку реалізації gate T, наприклад, ми
вміємо застосовувати gate T до вхідного стану. Але для цього нам, здається, потрібно застосовувати gate T до стану плюс, щоб отримати
магічний стан. І ситуація схожа для реалізації gate S. Суть у тому, що нам
не обов'язково потрібно спочатку створювати стан плюс, а потім застосовувати gate T, щоб отримати магічний стан. Є інші можливі способи отримати цей стан. І
зокрема, ми можемо зробити це, не турбуючись про поширення помилок у будь-якому обчисленні, над яким ми працюємо, тому що магічні стани можуть бути створені
окремо. Це дозволяє відмовостійку реалізацію gate T, яку я зараз коротко опишу.
По-перше, ми насправді не будемо запускати простий двокубітний circuit, показаний тут, а натомість запустимо цей circuit за допомогою
qubit, закодованих у будь-якому коді виправлення помилок, що ми використовуємо для нашої відмовостійкої реалізації. Це означає, що
унітарні gate та вимірювання виконуються відмовостійкими гаджетами. А це означає, що нам також потрібні наші
магічні стани, що теж закодовані. Тому все буде відмовостійким, поки ми можемо отримати
закодовані магічні стани. Ми тут припускаємо, до речі, що у нас вже є відмовостійкий гаджет для gate S. Якщо
ми використовуємо код Стіна, наприклад, ми могли б просто реалізувати gate S трансверсально. А для кодів, де це не працює, один варіант —
спочатку використати всю цю схему для відмовостійкої реалізації gate S, а потім використати цю реалізацію тут.
Хоча це не єдиний варіант. Але так чи інакше, повертаючись до реалізації, важливе питання, що залишається — як ми отримуємо
закодований магічний стан, враховуючи, що у нас ще немає відмовостійкої реалізації gate T, щоб зробити це
простим? І ключова ідея полягає в тому, що ми можемо використовувати імовірнісний процес для створення закодованих магічних станів. І якщо він
виявиться невдалим, то це нормально. Ми можемо просто викинути невдалі спроби і спробувати знову.
І це не порушує обчислення, яке ми насправді намагаємося виконати, тому що створення магічних станів здійснюється
окремо. Типовий спосіб, яким це робиться — через процес, відомий як дистиляція магічних станів. І він працює ось як.
У нас є певний circuit, відомий як дистилятор. Ми вводимо в цей дистилятор набір зашумлених магічних
станів, а потім вимірюємо всі виходи, крім одного. І якщо ми обумовлюємо всі результати вимірювань рівними нулю,
то відбувається таке: на виході ми отримуємо менш зашумлений магічний стан, який потім може бути одним з qubit, що вводяться в
інший дистилятор. І процес продовжується, поки ми або не зазнаємо невдачі, тому що один з результатів вимірювань ненульовий, і спробуємо знову, або не отримаємо магічний
стан достатньо високої якості, щоб безпечно використати його для реалізації gate T в обчисленні, яке нас цікавить.
Є різні відомі способи побудови такого дистилятора, але всі вони працюють в основному однаково, а саме — це декодери стабілізаторних кодів,
тобто обернені до кодувальних circuit, що приємно, тому що це означає, що дистилятор може бути операцією Кліффорда.
І нарешті, цей процес дистиляції насправді відбувається на рівні логічного qubit. Тому в реальності все це
робиться за допомогою гаджетів для дистилятора та вимірювань. Цей процес все ж повинен
десь починатися. Але поки рівень шуму не надто великий, можна створити зашумлені, але достатньо хороші
магічні стани для його початку. Наприклад, застосувавши справжній зашумлений gate T до qubit у стані плюс, а потім
закодувавши цей qubit. Отже, це був дуже високорівневий опис, але сподіваюся, що я дав тобі приблизне уявлення про те, як це працює.
Це значно складніше, ніж реалізація gate трансверсально, але тим не менш, це пропонує спосіб реалізувати універсальний набір квантових
gate відмовостійко, тоді як трансверсальні реалізації gate самі по собі не можуть цього. Іноді стверджується,
що накладні витрати на використання магічних станів для відмовостійкої реалізації gate в цьому напрямку були б дуже високими,
де переважна більшість роботи йде на дистиляцію магічних станів, а запуск самого обчислення стає чимось другорядним.
Але це насправді не настільки очевидно, і були проведені детальні аналізи, що показують, що цей метод
насправді може бути практичним. Є кілька інших відомих схем для відмовостійкої реалізації gate. Деформація коду та перемикання коду — назви,
пов'язані з деякими з цих схем, і нові способи продовжують розроблятися та вдосконалюватися, але я не опишу ці
методи в цьому уроці. Є ще одне важливе питання, що стосується відмовостійких реалізацій квантових circuit, і
воно стосується самих кроків виправлення помилок. Тому це не про реалізацію gate. Це про виконання
самого виправлення помилок. Проблема в тому, що якщо ми думаємо про прості circuit, які ми
вперше побачили в уроці 14 для вимірювання генераторів стабілізаторів на основі фазової оцінки, ми знаходимо, що вони не є
самі по собі відмовостійкими, тому що вони потенційно можуть спричиняти поширення помилок всередині одного блоку коду.
Це повертається до ідеї, що все, що стосується квантової інформації, є сприйнятливим до помилок, і це включає circuit, які самі по собі призначені
для виправлення помилок. Це здається досить проблематичним, але насправді відомі кілька рішень цієї проблеми. Я згадаю лише кілька з
них, хоча не поясню жодного з них детально. І до речі, якщо ти відчуваєш, що відмовостійкі квантові обчислення є
складними і є багато деталей, про які треба хвилюватися, то це, звичайно, зрозуміло, тому що це правда. Тут є багато рухомих частин,
і мій намір з цим уроком — не пояснити всі деталі, а скоріше дати тобі лише базове введення в те, як все це
працює. Один метод для відмовостійкого квантового виправлення помилок відомий як виправлення помилок Шора, названий на честь Пітера
Шора, який першим запропонував цей метод. Ідея полягає в виконанні кожного вимірювання синдрому за допомогою так званого стану cat,
який є тим самим, що і стан GHZ, коли у нас три qubit, але він може бути узагальнений до будь-якої кількості qubit, що відповідає вазі генератора стабілізатора,
який ми маємо намір виміряти. Зокрема, circuit, показаний тут, працює для вимірювання генератора стабілізатора. І можна
показати, що цей метод не спричиняє поширення помилок всередині блоку коду.
Це потребує створення самого стану cat. І щоб він надійно працював у присутності помилок та потенційно несправних gate, метод насправді
вимагає, щоб ми неодноразово запускали подібні circuit і робили висновки про те, де могли виникнути різні помилки протягом
цього процесу. Альтернативний метод відомий як виправлення помилок Стіна, вперше запропонований Ендрю Стіном, і цей
WEBVTT
метод працює по-іншому і діє лише для CSS-кодів. У цьому методі ми насправді не виконуємо вимірювання синдромів на закодованих квантових
станах у circuit, який ми намагаємося запустити, а натомість ми навмисно поширюємо помилки до робочої системи
і потім вимірюємо цю систему та класично виявляємо помилки. Ця схема, показана тут, демонструє, як це зробити для помилок X, у якому випадку робочі
qubit спочатку встановлюються до кодування стану плюс. Тому це в основному
трансверсальна реалізація gate C not, яка нічого не повинна робити, тому що цільовий qubit перебуває у стані плюс. Але якщо
є помилки X у верхніх qubit, вони поширяться на нижню систему і будуть виявлені. Є також схожий метод для виявлення помилок Z,
який тут не показаний. Є також пов'язаний метод, відомий як виправлення помилок Кнілла, вперше запропонований Менні Кніллом,
і він базується на телепортації, а не на трансверсальному C not, що дозволяє йому працювати для довільних стабілізаторних
кодів, а не лише для CSS-кодів.
Остання річ, яку я обговорю в цьому уроці — дуже важлива теорема, відома як теорема про поріг. Ось дещо неформальне
формулювання теореми. Вона стверджує, що якщо у нас є будь-який квантовий circuit, що має n gate, де n може бути настільки великим, як нам завгодно, то
можна реалізувати цей circuit з високою точністю за допомогою зашумленого квантового circuit за умови, що рівень шуму
нижче певного порогового значення, що не залежить від n. Більш того, це не надто дорого
в тому сенсі, що розмір необхідного зашумленого circuit має порядок n, помноженого на деякий постійний степінь логарифма
від n. Для більш формального формулювання теореми потрібно бути конкретним щодо моделі шуму, чого я не робитиму в цьому уроці.
Наприклад, це може бути доведено для моделі незалежного стохастичного шуму, яку я згадував раніше, де помилки виникають
незалежно в кожному можливому місці circuit з деякою ймовірністю, що строго менша за це порогове значення. Але це також може бути
доведено для більш загальних моделей шуму, де можуть бути кореляції між помилками. Тепер, це теоретичний
результат, і типовий спосіб його доведення не обов'язково перекладається в те, що ми б насправді робили на практиці, але він тим не менш є дуже
важливою теоремою в практичному сенсі. І причина в тому, що вона в основному стверджує, що немає фундаментального бар'єру для виконання
квантових обчислень за допомогою зашумлених компонентів.
Поки рівень помилок для цих компонентів нижче цього порогового значення, їх можна використовувати для побудови надійних квантових circuit довільного
розміру. Інший спосіб це сказати: якби теорема не була правдивою, важко уявити, як масштабні квантові обчислення
колись стали б реальністю. У формальних доведеннях цієї теореми задіяно багато технічних деталей, які я не намагатимуся
передати. Але я спробую пояснити базову ідею на високому рівні. І я також спробую вільно зв'язати базову
ідею з тим, що ми могли б очікувати відбуватиметься на практиці. Тож припустимо, що це наш circuit. Це той самий circuit, про який
ми говорили протягом усього уроку. Але знову ж таки, ми можемо уявити, що наш circuit значно більший і складніший за цей. Ми хотіли б
реалізувати цей circuit, але всі наші компоненти зашумлені. І припускаючи, що ми використовуємо модель незалежного стохастичного шуму
просто для простоти, є деяка ймовірність P, з якою помилки виникають незалежно в кожному можливому місці.
Якщо circuit був значно більший за обернену величину до цієї ймовірності P, то ми могли б бути досить впевнені, що
пряма реалізація не спрацювала б правильно. Тому ми проходимо через увесь процес реалізації circuit
відмовостійко, як я обговорив до цього моменту в уроці, і ставимо собі питання, яке я підняв раніше: ми покращуємо ситуацію
чи погіршуємо? Ну, якщо ймовірність P, що представляє ймовірність помилки для кожного з наших компонентів, надто велика, то
це не допоможе, так само як 9-qubit код Шора не допомагає, якщо ймовірність помилки вище 3 і 3/4% або близько того.
Зокрема, ми тепер зробили circuit більшим. Тому є набагато більше місць, де можуть виникнути помилки.
Однак, якщо P достатньо мале, це допоможе. І те, що ми фактично зробимо — зменшимо ймовірність помилки
для логічного обчислення, яке ми виконуємо. Тож подумаймо про це ще
трохи детальніше. І щоб побачити основні ідеї в якомога простішому контексті, припустимо, що ми використовуємо 7-qubit код Стіна для виправлення
помилок, який дозволяє виправляти до однієї помилки на блок коду. Тому для того, щоб логічна помилка
виникла у вихідному circuit, нам доведеться мати принаймні дві помилки, що потрапляють у той самий блок коду для нашої відмово
стійкої реалізації.
Маючи на увазі, що є багато різних способів мати дві або більше помилок в одному блоці коду, можна стверджувати, що ймовірність логічної
помилки в кожному місці вихідного circuit становить щонайбільше C * P ^ 2, де C — число, що залежить від коду та
гаджетів, що ми використовуємо. Але критично, воно не залежить від розміру вихідного circuit.
Тому якщо P менше за обернене до C, яке є числом, що ми можемо взяти як наше порогове значення, то це
перетворюється на зменшення помилки. Тому наша тяжка праця з відмовостійкою реалізацією circuit дає
результат. Однак ця нова частота помилок може бути ще надто великою для правильної роботи всього circuit. Тому нам потрібно
зробити більше. На практиці природним рішенням на цьому етапі є вибір кращого коду та кращих гаджетів для зниження частоти
помилок до точки, де реалізація, ймовірно, спрацює.
З теоретичної точки зору, простий спосіб довести, що це можливо — виконати конкатенацію. Іншими словами, ми
думаємо про відмовостійку реалізацію вихідного circuit як про новий логічний circuit. А потім реалізуємо його відмово
стійко. А потім робимо це знову і знову стільки разів, скільки нам потрібно. І виявляється, що це зменшує помилку
дуже швидко. І саме так теорема про поріг зазвичай доводиться на папері.
Я дам тобі лише дуже приблизне уявлення про те, як зменшується частота помилок, залишаючи без уваги багато технічних деталей, необхідних для
формального доведення. Ми починаємо з ймовірності помилки P для наших вихідних компонентів. І якщо ми реалізуємо
circuit відмовостійко, помилка зменшується в C * P разів. Якщо ми потім розглянемо нашу відмовостійку
реалізацію як логічний circuit і реалізуємо її відмовостійко, ми отримаємо подібне зменшення частоти помилок. Але
якщо ми думаємо про ефективну частоту помилок для вихідного circuit, ми знаходимо, що вона падає ще нижче, тому що тепер
ми замінюємо частоту помилок P на C * P ^ 2, тому що це є ефективною частотою помилок після першого рівня відмово
стійкої реалізації. Зокрема, після невеликої алгебри ми знаходимо, що помилка знижується до CP
в кубі * P. І якщо ми робимо це знову, ми тепер маємо частоту помилок CP ^ 7 * P. І якщо
WEBVTT
ми продовжуємо робити це всього K рівнів, ми знаходимо, що помилка зменшується подвійно експоненційно в K. Тому нам
не потрібно робити це дуже багато разів, щоб зробити частоту помилок надзвичайно малою.
Тим часом circuit зростають у розмірі, але розмір зростає лише однократно експоненційно в K, тому що з кожним
рівнем відмовостійкості розмір нашого circuit зростає щонайбільше в коефіцієнт, що визначається максимальним розміром
наших гаджетів. І коли все це зведено воєдино та зроблено відповідний вибір для кількості
рівнів конкатенації, ми отримуємо теорему про поріг. Але, як я вже припустив, для формалізації цього потрібно багато деталей. Тож
яке ж це порогове значення насправді? Ну, це залежить від коду та від гаджетів,
що ми використовуємо для коду Стіна разом із дистиляцією магічних станів. Воно мізерне і, мабуть, навряд чи досяжне
на практиці. Але використовуючи поверхневі коди та сучасні гаджети, воно оцінюється приблизно в 1%. Що
непогано. І в міру відкриття нових кодів і методів, ми можемо обґрунтовано очікувати його збільшення, тоді як одночасно
рівень шуму в компонентах, які ми будуємо, зменшуватиметься. Досягти точки, в якій
масштабні квантові обчислення можуть бути реалізовані відмовостійко, буде нелегко і це не відбудеться за одну ніч.
Але ця теорема разом із досягненнями в квантових кодах і квантовому обладнанні, які ми спостерігали до сьогодні,
надає нам оптимізм, необхідний для того, щоб продовжувати рухатися вперед до цієї кінцевої мети — побудови
масштабного відмовостійкого квантового комп'ютера. І це кінець уроку і кінець серії. Я
щиро сподіваюся, що ти знайшов цінність у серії, і якщо так, будь ласка, порекомендуй її колезі або другу.
Також обов'язково перевір IBM Quantum Learning для додаткових курсів та навчальних матеріалів і підпишись на
YouTube-канал Qiskit, якщо ще не зробив цього, щоб бути в курсі наших майбутніх релізів контенту. Дякую за
перегляд.